>> KURZKE: Thanks everyone for coming for
our session. I've been told if you want, you
can rearrange the chairs a little bit to make
it more comfortable for you to actually see
the stage. This one is more of a presentation.
It's not as much as hands-on lab. So, you
don't really need your laptop if you can go
with--like an hour without checking email.
I know it's hard to do.
>> SAXMAN: No chance.
>> KURZKE: I know. So, thanks everyone. Welcome
to our talk about Google TV and we're going
to talk about the current version of Google
TV. Myself, I am Christian Kurzke. I am the
developer advocate for the Android platform
on Google TV. I joined the team about a year
ago and I've been working with the preloaded
Android applications, so, the Napster, Pandora,
Twitter Apps, all the good stuff that's on
your TV today. And with me is Paul.
>> SAXMAN: My name is Paul Saxman and I'm
relatively new to the Google TV Team. But
I have quite a bit of Android background.
I built quite a few apps and I truly believe
that Google TV is the new frontier for Android
app development.
>> KURZKE: We're the Wild West. So, what we
also have here is--let's see, hopefully we
have a next slide. Yes. So, we have this thing
called Speaker Meter. We're going to use throughout
Google IO. You can give us live feedback to
either on Twitter, I'm not going check it
here but I will look at it later, or Speaker
Meter, this is for each session. You can just
try and scan the QR code and give us feedback
on it later.
>> SAXMAN: And we are going to have a Q&A
at the end. So--and actually, when--we do
have that microphone up here for everybody
to use. So, feel free to line up near the
end of the talk.
>> KURZKE: Okay. So actually, just to give
a quick hand--show of hands. So, how many
of you are actually Android developers and
have developed Android apps? Awesome, very
good. And how many Web developers do we have
here or people who are not so familiar? Good,
good. So, hopefully, we'll try to keep it
pretty high-level and pretty generic. So,
we should have something for all of you. We'll
go a little bit into detail but here's the
overview.
>> SAXMAN: Yes. Yes. So, here's a breakdown
of what Christian and I are going to talk
about today. We're going to start off with
an overview of the Google TV platform. And
then, start to talk about building native
Android apps and Web apps, kind of at high-level.
We're then going to talk a little bit about
how you decide what to build because it's
kind of a tough question which direction you
want to go sometimes. We're then going to
segue into building Android apps for Google
TV a little more deeper--deeply, covering
how to get set up with the environment. Google
TV displays, types of apps and tips on navigation
and layout, which are very pretty very important.
And finally, we'll be sure to keep some time
at the end for Q&A. Since this is BootCamp
and there's a lot of news coming the next
couple of days, today, we're going to focus
on what Google TV is now and how you can start
developing for the platform today but won't
be talking about the next version of Google
TV yet. So, please keep in mind--keep that
in mind during the Q&A. And, however, we do
think that there's a lot of great information
in this talk for developers interested in
Google TV as the new platform for Android
development. So, without further ado, let's
talk about the Google TV platform. So, what
is Google TV? Google TV is a platform that
opens the living room to the Web, making television
more relevant and engaging. It accomplishes
this by bringing together a sophisticated
and open applications platform, which is Android,
and a full HTML5 capable Web browser, which
is Chrome. And also, it brings all this together
with the power of search. Like, Android for
mobile devices and tablets, it's one platform
for multiple devices.
>> KURZKE: So, from a little bit more of a
technical point of view, just also some of
the, you know, clarifying some of the conceptions
that people have--so we really want to bring
internet content and interactive content together
with your existing TV content. So, Google
TV--sometimes in the press after the launch,
there was this sort of connotation that it
would replace your existing cable subscription.
And it's really not the intention. So, we
are trying to bring new content together with
your old content that you already have on
your TV. So, most people, at least here in
the US, sort of the standard set up is you
have a satellite box or a cable box and your
cable box connects to your TV and you have
a DVR and you have all really great set up
with an audio system and everything. What
we want is we want Google TV, in this case
here, I'm showing the logitech box integrate
with your existing setup. It would sit between
your cable box and your TV and it would bring
you additional content from the internet.
So, you can--today already, you can have,
on your Web browser, you can go to optimize--TV
optimized websites or you can run some of
the pre-installed Android applications. So,
if you already have a Google TV, you can run
the Pandora app, you can run Netflix app,
you can stream movies, and it brings it to
the largest display in your house, to the
TV.
>> SAXMAN: So, to--let's take a quick look
at the history of Google TV to help understand
where it is today. It was announced just about
a year ago at IO, and a few months after that,
the Sony and Logitech Google TV devices were
available to the--or available on the market.
Those devices are based on Android 2.1 and
like Christian mentioned, they have several
Android applications preloaded. In December
of last year, the Android remote control app
was released, which was received pretty well.
And in January of this year, we announced
two new OEM partners, Samsung and Vizio. And
finally at this last March, we released an
iPhone version of the remote app, which also
is pretty highly received. So, looking at
this timeline, something you should note is
that Google TV is still a relatively young
platform. As with Android on mobile devices,
we brought Google TV to the market quickly
so that we can get user's feedback. And this
year, we have collected a lot of great feedback
and we are incorporating it into Google TV
so that it can become a great device.
>> KURZKE: And I think also what's really
interesting about Google TV is it will be
an interesting platform for Android developers,
we have announced last year that we will bring
market and we will have the ability for developers
to develop applications for it. So, just look
at it like the G1 device, it's still very
early in the curve, but also earlier this
year, as Paul mentioned in January, at CES,
we announced two new hardware OEMs. So, there's
going to be a large footprint of devices in
the market. So, what is it from a user's point
of view? One thing you always have to keep
in mind when you develop applications, what
is the context in which your application will
be used. And I think what you have to keep
in mind is when you develop an app for Google
TV, sort of put yourself in the mindset of
your user, it's like lean back on a couch
in the living room after a long day at work
with the remote control and probably a bag
of chips in the other hand. So, it's really
a different mindset than what your user has
when they interact with your website. When
you're maybe, in the office, you're between
meetings, you're checking a website, you're,
I don't know, going to your favorite eCommerce
website or something. So, the TV is more of
a leisure, more of an entertainment device
and people spend a lot of time consuming content.
So, what we really want to accomplish with
Google TV is make the TV experience more interactive
and just at least when you develop an app
for it, it gives you one path for the user
where they normally wouldn't have your app
in front of them. And we know a lot of people
today when they watch TV, they have their
mobile phone or maybe their tablet, they check
Twitter or they check some of their other
social networks and the TV has the potential
to bring all these together. So, here's another
home screen, or here's a snapshot of the home
screen, in case you haven't seen Google TV
and I know last year, a lot people who were
at Google IO, they actually received a Google
TV, a box, an early version. So, this is what
it looks like. It--in the background, you
see a live television. So this here was a
travel channel. You just click the home "Home"
button and it overlays the home on top of
your live TV. And it gives you very quick
access, In this case, to Android applications.
So, you see, a menu on the side here, you
can have browser bookmarks you can have Android
apps. And here's just a selection of some
of the Android apps that are preloaded on
the box. So, you have--what we chose a portfolio
of typical apps that people may want in their
living room, we have something for sports
fans, you have your Netflix, you have your
Pandora. So, I think it's an interesting platform
for users to get content while they're watching
TV.
>> SAXMAN: I think, you know, one point--one
thing to point out here too is it's not just
a big phone, you know what I mean? It's really
a different type of device with a different
type of interface, even though it's all built
on top of Android.
>> KURZKE: Yes. So, this Android app, I mean,
it's already--sort of the first indication--by
the way, the home screen, of course, is also
implemented in Android. But it's an indication
of how you should layout your app, you know,
make it very, very light on information. Keep
a lot of open space, people don't want to
see pages and pages of text on their TV screen.
That's not an eReader. So, the other component
of Google TV is the remote control. If you
think about how people interact with your
Android application today, virtually, all
Android applications use a touch interface,
use a touch screen. Google TV, people sit
10 feet away from the screen and it would
be very inconvenient if they have to get up
and walk to the TV and touch stuff. I think
that's why we invented remote controls, that's
what the TV is used to be. So, Google TV comes
with remotes. What we want is a full QWERTY
keyboard, I personally really hate when I
have to search for shows and I have to have
an onscreen keyboard and navigate through
ABCD. So, all the Google TVs come with a QWERTY
keyboard, they do have a mouse pointer of
sorts. So, the Sony remote, for example, it
has a little optical mouse joystick. But one
of the main things is, it's not a touch screen.
So keep that in mind also and we'll go over
some of the implications later. One key that
I want to highlight is the search key. We
really believe that Google TV should help
you find content that's relevant for you much
faster, after all Google is really a search
company, we know a lot about searching. So,
we want to make it very easy for you when
you watch TV to find content. So there's a
dedicated search key for the Android guys
amongst you, it brings up the system search,
the system search box which we call the quick
search box. And I'll show you what that looks
like. So, on Google TV, when you press the
search key and you enter a term, it will go
through the system search, it will bring you
content from different sources. So in this
case, it's mainly YouTube content but it could
also be content that's relevant for your TV
channel. So if you search for something were
you have, let's say, a DVR recording or it's
a show that's coming in the future, you can
schedule a recording. And for developers,
it's really cool because, as you see in the
bottom here, you can actually contribute results.
So in this case, a YouTube application and
the Amazon application contributed results
to this. So if you've developed an app that
wants to get in front of the user and maybe,
you know, search through your media library
or search through your photos, you can also
contribute search results here. On this screen,
I want to point out the little icon in the
bottom. So this is, today, were the notifications
show up. I've heard people describe the Android
notification as sort of the new inbox. It's
like, people get so much email, you don't
even read email anymore but when something
shows up in your notification bar, you typically--it
grabs your attention. So, this is where notifications
show up today, and in this case, the Pandora
app as you may know from your cellphone, every
time it plays a new track, it notifies you
just to keep you current if you're interested--what
you're listening to in the background, maybe.
So in this case, Pandora threw up a notification
and said, "Hey, you know, I'm having a really
great new sound and--that I'm listening for."
And the copyright owners of those probably
don't mind. So, yeah, so this is our Pandora
notification box and it's also a great way
for you as an Android developer, it uses the
regular Android notification APIs, so if your
app has something new and exciting going on,
you want the user to either be reminded of
or maybe you just want to get in front of
the user again, you can open up a notification
or you can send a notification and the user
can open up the dialog. So, those last things,
the search, the notification, it's all really
pretty good integration but Google TV, as
we said earlier, it's based on the Android
platforms, and one of the really cool things
you can do in Android is your application
can integrate pretty deeply into the platform.
So, on a mobile phone, you have a lot of ways,
you have live wallpapers; you have things
like widgets and so on. And on TV, there's
a lot of ways--for example, here, you see
a live folder, so the user can configure the
live folder showing the tweet timeline to
show up right on the home screen. So you can
imagine, as a developer, it's not just a very
standalone experience, it's not start an app,
interact with an app and go back to the TV
watching. But, we really want to enable developers
to get in front of users and get integrated
into the system. I think that's one, for me,
I'm an Android guy, so I come from the Android
world. It's one of the really cool things
that Android enables you to do. So, now that
you've seen all the things that are possible,
why would you develop an app for Google TV?
I mean, besides, being a really cool platform,
it's also typically the largest display in
the house. Every time I visit my friends now
and they have a little picture frame that
shows like their last notification photos
on like the two inch LCD or whatever, four
inch LCD. I'm like, what's the point? Just
use a TV. You have a 60 inch picture frame.
So it's the largest display and you can just
go wild and imagine what you as a developer
could show on the screen. I mean, there's
a lot of really cool apps that are possible.
It's also connected to a really amazing sound
system. Typically, your TV or your hi-fi stereo
in the living room, you don't need to plug
anything in, Google TV is already connected
to it and you as an app developer can use
the sound system. And the other thing is,
supposedly in America, people spend five hours
a day watching TV. Keep in mind, this is not
America, I know you guys probably spend a
lot more time on your computer. But this is
a stat--just looking at the media habits of
teenagers, eight to eighteen year olds, even
if you take everything else together, gaming,
consoles, listening to music, playing video
games, sitting on the computer, they spent--still
spend 42% of their time more than computer
and video games together, just watching TV.
So, being able to create applications around
the TV, I think is really exciting for developers.
And, I think that's also why we have gotten
a lot of really excited developers who keep
asking us, "So when can I get my app onto
Google TV?" And, as we said, we're not going
to make any new announcements today but we
stand by what we said last year. It's--the
market is coming later this year and we're
working on it, we're very focus on it.
>> SAXMAN: So, now that we know what Google
TV is, let's talk a little bit about how to
develop for Google TV. From a developer's
perspective, Google TV is really about the
power of choice. Google TV is--it's actually
Android and the Web in one box and it's not
just the Web but it's the HTML5 in a full
Chrome Web browser which is different than
most Android devices. So basically, this isn't
your grandmother's Web on TV, I mean this
is a full Web experience. So given that developers
can take advantage of the Android platform
and a full Chrome Web browser, how should
they decide what type of app to build? To
help answer that question; let's first take
a look at what the Android platform has to
offer. Android takes the Java language to
new heights with APIs for layouts, graphic
rendering, search, media, databases, the list
goes on and on. And since these APIs are shared
across all Android devices, the code developed
on top of these APIs can be reused on mobile,
tablet, and Google TV devices. And in some
instances, the same app can be used in all
three types of devices and it's--that's entirely
possible. The apps themselves can be installed
in a device with just a couple of clicks and
they automatically update if the user allows
it, which is a benefit to both users and developers.
Back to the APIs, since many of the Android
APIs access the hardware directly, developers
can leverage system hardware to accelerate
performance and gain more control over how
system resources are utilized. As a software
platform, Android has a number of features
that help developers design rich user interfaces
and streamline information flow. This list
is actually--the list on the--the slide here
is actually just a small subset of what Android
has to offer to developers. We've cover some
of these features already, such as notifications.
And many of these will be discussed further
at IO. But in summary, the Android platform
gives developers full control over both hardware
and software keyboards and buttons, and most
cert--most notably the "back" and "search"
buttons which is actually a big benefit; the
ability to share data with other apps and
display custom search results; the ability
to push notifications to users from background
services; a full multithreading based on Java
threads; and a very rich application framework
which includes intents, activities and services.
All you Android guys are going to be very
familiar with all of this. The main takeaway
here is that the Android platform gives developers
a lot of control over the design of their
apps in terms of the interfaces and their
architecture. There are definitely a lot of
opportunities; a lot more opportunities to
hear about Android features at IO, but for
Google TV in particular, don't forget to miss
Christian and Jason's talk on Wednesday, that's
this guy here; in case you're looking for
him in the hallway before hand, so. Here's
another very good example of the power of
Google TV in the Android platform. Here, we
see the Google--the quick search box again.
The user has entered discovery off of his
or her search query. And we see results from
the Web and the user's lineup, like we'd expect,
which is very useful. And I see "MythBusters,
Table Cloth Chaos" coming up in seven minutes
which is actually one that I think I've missed,
so maybe we want to cut this a little short.
We also see that there are results from YouTube,
Napster, and Amazon. We see these services
listed here with their exact number of search
results since each service has an Android
app installed on Google TV, and each app has
a searchable content provider for the information
it manages. By using Android's APIs, developers
can deeply integrate their app with the Google
TV platform. And what's unfortunately not
shown here, apps can actually share information
with one another. So on the other hand, for
Chrome and the Web; developers have access
the HTML5, CSS, JavaScript, and the Flash
platform, all of which are very powerful tools
for content delivery. Using this suite of
technologies is relatively straight forward
for developers to create interfaces that work
on multiple form, factors and displays, including
mobile screens, medium and high density tablets,
desktop computers and televisions. There are
a variety of tools for developing Web applications
many of which were created or refined over
a number of years to make Web development
very quick and easy. And if you already have
an existing Web application, you can likely
reuse most if not all of your content and
code when you're creating a Google TV-enhanced
website. If you do develop a truly great Web
application, your app could be feature on
the Google TV spotlight which highlights the
latest and greatest Web-based Google TV apps
available. And finally, with the Web, there's
no need for developers to download or install
your app, and updating is seamless. As soon
as you published its content, it's available
to end users. And along those lines, for more
information, if you're interested in building
Web apps for Google TV, don't miss Chris and
Dan's Tech Talk on Wednesday as well. Different
times so you could actually make it to both.
So here's an example of a Web application
optimize for Google TV. The first thing that
you'll likely notice is that this app doesn't
look--doesn't look like a traditional website
at all and it looks like a TV application.
However, if you're familiar with HTML and
CSS, you know that this page could easily
be modified to look good on mobile devices,
tablets or PCs. It's just a matter of changing
a few parameters around. This app gives TV
viewers easy access to the information that
they're likely to want via streamlined interface
with easy to read fonts, plenty of padding
and simple navigation. And it also has full
content search capability which is not integrated
into the Google TV platform but Google TV
really has no problem searching Web content.
>> KURZKE: So just to wrap up in summary,
I think for both, for Web developers and for
Android developers, just some things to keep
in mind is really using large font sizes.
Your application is typically viewed in a
living room environment. People sit far back.
Reading paragraphs of text is hard. You don't
want too many line breaks in your text. The
other thing is on television, keep in mind
there are two major resolutions that are supported
by modern televisions. It's called 1080p and
720p. So, that's the number of lines. So,
one is 1920 by 1080. The other is 1280 by
720. And also, really when you design and
sometimes it's different when you're in a
mobile mindset you always try to squeeze as
much information as you can on the limited
number of pixels. On TV just use larger icons.
Keep more space between the icons. Make it
easy to navigate and don't overload the user
with too much information. What we have found
just over the last couple iterations that
we've gone through is it's better to have
more a progressive disclosure. If you have
more information available, make it visible
to the user but then give them a choice so
either go into more details. Sometimes it's
easier to just show, say, a short video clip.
The website that we saw, that Paul showed,
with--just like a TV show information, having
the cover art there or having a screenshot
there is probably a lot more relevant to TV
users than having the full bio of all the
actors. If they want that information, you
can give them the option to get it but try
to keep the amount of information on the screen
pretty light.
>> SAXMAN: So, with all the benefits of these
two platforms, it still might be hard to decide
which one to use to develop your app, so ultimately
you might have to make a pragmatic decision.
There are a few questions to help guide you
in making this decision though. Basically,
are you currently working on an Android app
that you'd like to see on Google TV? Or do
you already have a Web-based application that
you could migrate? Or if you've-- you had
to start working on an Android app or website
do you have existing code or expertise that
you could use? For performance, do you need
access to Android's low-level APIs or is the
performance that you get with Chrome enough,
which is actually usually more than enough?
And finally, do you want to share information
with the Google TV platform or other Android
applications like we saw with search? If so,
building an Android is definitely going to
be the right choice. And there's actually
a really good talk coming up if you're still
looking for more information about HTML versus
Android. It's also going to be at Wednesday.
It's a different time than the other two talks,
so I think you could...
>> KURZKE: You can do both.
>> SAXMAN: ...go to all three.
>> KURZKE: Yeah, you can do them three in
a row and after that you'll know everything
about Google TV.
>> SAXMAN: Exactly. Yeah. So, yeah, definitely
be sure to stop by and check that out.
>> KURZKE: So, just, yeah, in summary here.
>> SAXMAN: Yeah. I'm just going to say, before
we dive into the specifics of building Android
apps on Google TV, here are some pointers
to getting started with building Web applications.
The rest of the talk is going to be about
Android so, you know, this is your last chance
to look this stuff up. Again, be sure to stop
by Chris and Dan's Tech Talk on Wednesday.
Visit the Google TV Documentation Website,
lots of great information there. Right now
you can see it's targeted towards Web but,
you know, we have Android documentation coming
as well. Join the Google TV Web Developers
Forum where there's lots of discussion about
building Web apps for Google TV. And finally,
check out the Google TV Website Gallery where
you can go for inspiration for building your
own apps. Even if you're sold on developing
a native Android app for Google TV, these
resources have a wealth of information for
developers that you absolutely shouldn't overlook.
So...
>> KURZKE: Cool. So, now I would like to share
with you some of the, you know, best practices
for developing Android apps and just some
of the lessons we have learned. And also for
people who are not familiar with Android I'm
actually very excited to see so many of you
already are Android developers, so I could
go over some of it a little faster. But in
order to develop Android apps, all the tools
you need are available to you for free. You
can download them. For Google TV since it's
just another compatible Android platform,
technically you can use the same tools and
really the difference is you're developing
for a large screen device. What you can do
with Android is you can have different resources
for different screen sizes or different resolutions.
So, in this example here I've just created
a regular Android project and I've created
resource folders for HDPI and XHDPI resolution.
And I'll explain a little more about this
later why those two. But if you are familiar
with Android, you know, resources can be things
like icons, can be graphics or it can be layouts.
So here is just another screenshot showing
you some of the dialogues. And the regular
Android SDK already gives you the opportunity
to create qualifiers for high density large
screens. And if you want to, you can add No
Touch to it just to explicitly call out that
this is for devices which don't have a touch
screen today. The other feature in the Android
SDK that you can use is you can create custom
layouts. Typically, when you install an off-the-shelf
Android SDK today, it will come with predefined
layouts or predefined screen sizes for the
layout editor for major like phone resolutions.
So we have the 480 by 800 for the Nexus class
phones, or we have the 1200--I think it's
1280 by 800 for tablets. If you want to develop
for Google TV, you would have to create your
own custom layout size for the screen resolution
of the Google TV. So, the way you would do
this is you just click on the little custom
icon and you can give it any name you want.
You can call it Google TV, whatever. And you
would configure it with the resolutions that
you expect your TV to have. And I'll share
a little bit of information with you. So,
the typical TV resolution that we find is
213 DPIs. So, that's a good value to use.
And I just called this the 720p resolution
and I defined the screen sizes as a 1280 by
720 screen size, high density. Of course,
it's a landscape device. So, that's one other
thing to keep in mind when you develop applications.
TVs typically only come in one orientation.
It's pretty hard to reorient the TV. It's
easier for yourself to lie on the couch. That
doesn't still make it a portrait. So, that's
just one way to define the layout editor.
And here's the reason I don't work in the
UX team. So, I just used all this and I created
a mock for Google TV application. So, I used
the parameters that I've just defined to create
a layout. And you can use the Android layout
editor in Eclipse and you can just drag and
drop very simple UIs. I've just taken a couple
of buttons, a couple of icons and a few checkboxes
and stuff and put it together on a UI, probably
not the best work I've ever done but it brings
across the point you can use the layout editor
with those custom layouts to create layouts
for large screens. So, why would you go through
all this hassle? You can also create an emulator
today. So you can use the Android SDK Emulator.
And as we said earlier today, Google TV runs
on API level seven, so that's Android 2.1
Eclair. So if you want to be compatible with
today's version, you can just create an emulator
based on this and you can set the screen size
to 1280 by 720 which is a reasonable value
for 720p and you set again the LCD density
to 213 and pick your value for heap size.
What you can do with this is you can start
an emulator and you can actually run your
app on an emulator. Here's an example, an
app running on a desktop emulator. It does
still show the phone menu bar on top if you
display the menu--or the top icon bar. Just
ignore that for now. Why would you want to
do that? Well, the reason is you can test
your app. You can test it up out on a large
screen, see if your layout scale, see if your
resources scale. It's just an exercise to
sort of get ahead of the curve and get your
app ready for, you know, maybe in the future.
This is not a replacement for running it on
on a real TV. But I think for a developer,
what I found is going through for example
this exercise with some of our partners, it's--sometimes
Android applications they look really nice
on a large screen. They basically just work
if you do all the right things. You use relative
layout. You use scalable nine-patch images.
But running your app on a large screen emulator,
it will point out typically a few hard-coded
assumptions that you may have made or it may
point out some of the bugs. So I think it's
a good practice, especially now that we have
tablets as well. Just try and run your app
on a large screen. See what it looks like
and it will help you, I think, create better
Android applications all the way around. So,
you may wonder how we came up with some of
the constants that I mentioned, so you may
have picked up--I used large screen. The first
question that everybody has is, if you're
familiar with Android, actually, this phone
here, the Nexus S, is considered a large screen,
how come my TV is not bigger than a Nexus
S? It's very simple; if you looked at it from
a 10-foot distance, you'll notice that the
TV actually appears fairly smaller in the
distance so we just took the large screen,
sort of--we believe that a TV should have
about as much information on it as your cell
phone application, as your mobile application.
And the other constant that I came up withóthe
resolution, so I used extra high density or
high density depending on 720 or 10 ATP, but
if you walk up close to a TV and you really
stand, like, as close to your TV as you would
stand to your tablet or to your phone, you
notice the physical resolution on the screen
is actually about 50 pixels per inch or you
can just do the math. And how do we get from
50 pixels to 200 pixels? It's again the distance.
The other advantage of this is if we choose
the extra high density, this will scale all
the Android DPs, the display independent pixels
or resolution independent pixels. So if you're
familiar with the way how Android handles
DPs and you do the math, you will realize
that your apps scale approximately twice as
much. So if you have extra high density is
320 DPs, as compared to a 160 DPs for normal
density. So if you just have an Android app
and you don't do anything and you just run
it on TV and you use DPs the way we recommend
in the documentation, then your app will scale
all the assets twice as much and you will
actually look reasonably well. So this is
really to make it easier for developers. As
Paul said earlier, to create one app that
runs across all devices. And I've actually--for
exercise purposes, created a few apps that
look really well on different displays. So
you can create really one layout that scales
nicely from a regular phone size through a
tablet all the way through a TV. Another bit
of TV technology that I want to point is,
a few of you are probably old enough to remember
that TVs used to have television CRTs with,
like, scan lines and electron beams and whole
lot of physics and stuff. And it's actually
really cool technology that's unfortunately,
still haunting us today. So the concept of
scan lines is still there and if you look
at 1080p resolution today, so the word 1080p,
it's actually the 1,080 scan lines that you
would have on an electron--on a good old-fashioned
CRT. And that is really the physical addressable
screen size that is available in TV. The other
thing that you may notice next time when you
watch, like, your favorite news channel or
your favorite sports channel, you'll probably
notice that they never put something that's
really super important all the way in the
corners because, actually, you never know
how much shows up on your consumer's television.
So if you look at the TV specs, they actually
specify about a five to ten percent safety
margin around the edge because back in the
days when it was electron beams zipping across
CRTs, you never knew if they were actually
calibrated properly. So TV broadcasters typically
show the relevant content, game scores or
stock tickers, they show stuff that's really
important about, you know, a couple of pixels
off the edge. And just to be on the safe side,
the recommendation is keep about 10% so you're
pretty safe that all the TV manufactures will
actually work with this. So what this means
for a developer is--I said early, we have
two main resolutions, we have 1080p and we
have 720p but when you create an app, you
can be pretty sure that it will not have the
full screen resolution running on your TV.
And that may be mechanical issues or mechanical
reasons like your decorative aluminum bezel
may actually cover up a couple of pixels on
each side. When you set up a Google TV, we
calibrate to the visible area on your screen.
And when you run an Android app and you do,
for example, a canvas that's full screen and
you donít get width, you may end up with
fewer pixels. And so the numbers that included
here, this is actually the worst-case scenario
so this is the 10% margin on each side so
that's really the minimum but also don't go
to the minimum. So my advice would really
be expect the worst but have relative layouts
that then float and use right aligned, left
aligned, top, bottom and make your UI look
pretty that way. And I think the best practices
for Android developers to really create a
great app that really stands out from the
rest is really using the dynamic layouts;
think about the overscan, test with the minimum
resolution, test with the maximum resolution.
One concept that I know we have been talking
about almost as long as Android is around
is 9-patch images. And especially designing
for TV, 9-patches get even more important.
Because if you think about it, basically the
amount of memory that you need for your onscreen
assets, for things like buttons, really grows
with the square basically of your resolution
because you need X and Y, if you double it,
you have four times as much memory for your
little icons. So using 9-patches to do the
scaling for you is really an elegant way to
do it. And, especially, I really encourage
developers to not put, like, pre-rendered
text on their buttons or something but use
the Android mechanisms to just bring the 9-patch
for the button background and then put a text
over it.
>> SAXMAN: And so, great internationalization
as well.
>> KURZKE: Definitely, yeah. I mean, it--the
way--what I found is running Android apps,
just random Android apps on Google TV, it
really shows which developers were sort of
keeping with the best practices, going the
extra mile, keeping it really dynamic layout.
And I think it really helps you find the couple
of bugs in your app. And keep in mind, your
user, a 10-foot design--you are creating apps
for somebody who just came home from work
and really just wants to kick back in their
recliner and watch TV and interact with your
app maybe.
>> SAXMAN: So Google TV apps actually come
in lots of different shapes and sizes and
how you design your app ultimately depends
on the use cases that you're targeting. You
can certainly have one app for multiple platforms
which is, by far, the hardest to implement
but really the easiest to maintain. Or you
could build separate apps actually tailored
to each of your use cases which are, you know,
for phones, tablets, and Google TVs. This
will allow you to target different but related
use cases by each app and take full advantage
of the higher resolutions of Google TV. This
is primarily true for full screen assets on
Google TV since it has a much higher resolution.
The third option is to build a companion app
that targets the same use cases in existing
app but is designed specifically for the Google
TV experience.
>> KURZKE: Yeah. I think, speaking of the
companion app, one thing to keep in mind also
is, the TV screen is usually a shared screen
in your living room. Your family is watching;
maybe on Sunday, you have your buddies over
and they're going to watch the TV. So, as
an app developer, keep that in mind, what
that sometimes means. So having, for example,
my tweet stream on TV, yeah, sure, that's
cool. I mean that's public information. But
having my personal inbox show up in notification
every time somebody sends me a tweet, you
may not want that when your buddies come over
on Sunday.
>> SAXMAN: So a couple of quick tips on, actually,
conquering the TV. If you really want to get
the greatest bang for your buck when building
your Google TV app, be sure to reuse as much
of existing Android code as possible. And
once you've identified what code you can reuse,
focus on user interface specifically, building
specialized user interfaces only where needed.
Really, the idea here is reduce, reuse, recycle,
and only redesign where necessary.
>> KURZKE: So here's a couple examples of
TV apps and so this is the mobile app from
CNBC and what we did is, when created the
TV app for CNBC, we worked with the team and
we looked at the mobile app, and we looked
at the Website and we found that the TV app
should probably be different from both experiences.
On the mobile phone you want to have your
stock portfolio, you want to have quick access
to information. The website is really to go
and find a lot more out--find background information.
So for the TV app, the team actually brought
in some of the interactive content--or not
interact--some of the visual content from
their CNBC channel and they added the broadcast
clips to the stock information. So they reused
a lot of their Android code from the mobile
phone so the whole portfolio management, all
the app logic is mainly reused from the mobile
app. And they also added the broadcast information.
So I worked with the CNBC team over the course
of last year to create the app that's on your
Google TV today. And what's actually really
exciting is they did almost of the opposite
of what you would be able to do. So they used
the mobile--they used the TV experience and
then actually optimized this to the table
experience. I saw they just--I think a couple
of days ago, launched their tablet app, it
looks very much like the TV app. And so, I
think, having the large screen Android devices
now is really an interesting opportunity to
create apps that work on larger screen and
maybe bring some more interactive visual content.
Here is another app which you maybe familiar
with. It's the Pandora Internet Radio App.
So it's--this is the mobile app, so they had
a very clean simple user interface, showing
the cover art, showing the artist's information,
and giving you a very quick, you know, thumbs-up,
thumbs-down sort of interface. They were actually
able to reuse most of their layout and most
of their code for the TV app. So this just
goes to show, if you have a user experience
that make sense in mobile and make sense on
the TV, you can virtually use most of your
app just as is. What they also did to optimize
is they used the key codes for our remote
control, so on the remote you can pause, forward,
play. And so they just used all those key
codes to make it much easier to interact with
the music player. So you don't have to use
the mouse cursor, and like go over and click
on buttons or use the 5-way navigation. So
those are just two examples that show how
you can take a mobile app and actually reuse
a lot of your work and transform it into a
TV experience.
>> SAXMAN: Okay. So before we wrap up there's
a couple more tips that we want to pass on
to you guys before you start building your
Google TV app. Christian just mentioned the
5-way navigation which is actually accomplished
via the D-Pad. Google TV devices have full
QWERTY keyboards and often have track pads
or some other form of touch-based navigation.
However, the primary mode of user interaction
with Google TV is 5-way or the--or D-Pad,
which is Directional Pad. When testing your
apps, keep your thumb on the D-Pad and not
the track pad, so that you can assure that
users are able to navigate quickly and easily
in your app. Same is true when using the emulator,
focus on your keyboard and the--and your directional
keys as opposed to using your mouse. Especially
keep D-Pad Navigation in mind when you're
designing your layouts. What we see here is
a fairly standard app interface which includes
the tab bar for changing between content,
a vertical list view in the center, and a
button down at the bottom there. This interface
is relatively common on mobile devices and
tablets since and is very compact and easy
to control with the tips of one's fingers.
However, things get more tricky if the user
navigates this interface using their D-Pad.
The issue is, is that if the user wants to
go from the tab to the button they actually
have to scroll through the entire list, in
the center there. So what we recommend in
this situation, is to actually re-orient your
layout. Here, we've actually taken the tabs
and the button, moved them to the left and
right of the vertically scrolling area. The
user can actually use their--the Directional
Pad up and down to navigate the tabs, up and
down to navigate within the vertical scrolling
list, and you know, left and right to scroll
between those three controls, so. It's still
a clean compact interface, but now it's very
easy to navigate using D-Pad.
>> KURZKE: Also, the one thing to keep in
mind is--what's very apparent is a lot of
apps typically are--when they are designed
for portrait mode, they have the--they'll
use a paradigm where you have list views and
then buttons in the bottom. When you have
a list view that's about four-feet wide, it
gets really hard to navigate. So if you have
like a check box on one side and the name
is on the other side, keeping list views narrow
and having multiple columns is usually a much
better user experience in general. So with
that, let's see, summary. We've pointed out,
there is a huge opportunity to create applications
for TV, and there is a large variety of devices
to target now, so especially for Android developers,
I mean, we're basically adding new devices
and we're adding new form factors as fast
as we can. I mean, we just gave you tablets.
Now there is TV, so there is--there is a huge
opportunity I think to leverage your Android
skills. The different screen sizes are definitely
giving you a whole new opportunity to create
new applications. Suddenly you have, basically,
a four square-foot or so display in the living
room that you can work on, or you have a whole
home theatre. And the good news is Android
already has a lot of built-in mechanisms to
support all these. So the Android APIs and
the Android, like all the mechanisms and the
best practices allow you to create apps for
phones, for tablets, for TVs and who knows
what's next. And then also, you can create
apps that easily support multiple platform
versions. So as Android developers, you're
probably already familiar with all the different
ways how you can create apps that run well
across different apps. So I would like to
do the--one little Steve Jobs thing. But wait,
I have one more thing for you. So actually,
I'm really thankful that you all stayed to
the end. So what I want to share for--share
with you is, we don't have this here today,
but starting tomorrow you can go to the Google
TV booth, and we have a little Sandbox on
the third floor, and pick up a flyer. So we
have this program that we call the Google
TV Fishtank and what we--what we want is if
you submit your ideas and if you give us great
ideas that you would want to implement on
Google TV, you can sign-up and we will look
at the submissions and we will select recipients
on a--on a rolling basis to receive developer
devices. So those developer devices will be
Google TV devices enabled with ADB, and you
as a developer can run your own apps and you
don't have to just run them on the desktop
emulator. I must say it's a really cool experience
to see your app the first time on your own
TV at home. So come back tomorrow to the Google
TV Sandbox on the third floor, pick-up a flyer
and we'll get you set-up with a really cool
development environment. All right. One question.
Can you please use the microphone?
>> Sure. Hypothetically, say that you're from
Sweden, would it still possible to enroll
in this program?
>> KURZKE: You would have to check with our
guys. I believe right now we're focusing mainly
on the U.S. but I think if you have an incredibly
compelling application, I encourage you to
talk with our business guys about that.
>> I'll think about that. Okay, thank you.
>> KURZKE: Yes, please.
>> If your apps use native code?
>> KURZKE: Yes. Sorry. So right now, since
Google TV--it also runs on Intel processors
we don't support native code currently.
>> Is that in the works to add that to the
emulator?
>> KURZKE: We're super-focused getting this
out, but I don't have a timeline on that.
[INDISTINCT]
>> Question about--is the Chrome browser we
see in the Google TV, so what type of difference
between the Chrome browser we see in Google
TV versus the Chrome browser running on a
standard PC, specially on the Chrome apps
store part?
>> KURZKE: I don't know the answer about the
Chrome apps store, but it is very much a Linux-based
Chrome browser. So by the way, if all of you
have more questions we have office hours and
a Sandbox upstairs where we have engineers
and we have actually two units that you can
see some demos on. So that's on the second
floor, kind of like this direction roughly.
So and I'll be hanging out there for a while
and I think Paul is going to be there most
of the day too.
>> SAXMAN: A yeah. We got a couple of more
minutes.
>> KURZKE: Yes.
>> SAXMAN: Go ahead.
>> Okay. I'm coming from a YouTube partner
channel-based background, and my question
to you guys is are you planning on developing
additional YouTube interfaces for Google TV
beyond what clearly looks like a very YouTube
beneficial search type--search type box?
>> KURZKE: So what Google TV already does
is we integrate with our video site map search,
so if you have video site maps for your content
on your site, that will definitely be surfaced.
Beyond that, I believe we have the YouTube
Leanback experience and you can also download
some of the CSS, and some of the samples to
get started. So if you as a partner want to
create optimized sites, so right now, we have--in
the Spotlight, we have for example, a VEVO
application which uses some of the YouTube
posted content, but adds additional just cover
information and stuff to it. So I think, if
you want to get really creative you could
create--you could use wrappers around the
YouTube experience.
>> Thanks.
>> Hi. Can you hear me? So I actually had
a one good question and a bad one.
>> KURZKE: Sure.
>> The good one is, how about identity? I
mean, one of the big things is, you, know
TV is shared, but all the other devices you're
talking about...
>> KURZKE: Right.
>> ...are individualized. Are you going to
do anything to allow multiple users, et cetera,
on the TV side?
>> KURZKE: So currently we don't have that
yet. And I think Android; in general, it's
more of a single user experience.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> KURZKE: So this is great feedback, and
we know this is something we need to work
on, so yes.
>> So the bad question now is, all the stuff
I'm hearing is still kind of treating the
applications as a secondarily app that's overlaid
on your content.
>> KURZKE: Yes.
>> But are you actually, at some point, going
to start allowing context to be shared between
them, so you can actually bring up apps related
to what you're watching without the user being
in the mix?
>> KURZKE: I think that is definitely a--I
think that's a very valid use case. What we
want to do in the future is have APIs specific
for TVs. We're not there yet, so stay tuned.
>> I was wondering what would happen if you
have an Android app that uses WebKit?
>> KURZKE: WebKit runs on Google TV today.
So you can just open up a Web view. We've
actually seen a couple of the developers do
that for content, so that would work.
>> It doesn't have to be rewritten because
the primary browser is Chrome?
>> KURZKE: No.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> SAXMAN: Not at all. We have the Web view
still works like [INDISTINCT].
>> KURZKE: Okay. Okay. Thanks everyone.